joining me to discuss is the shadow Home
Secretary Yvette Cooper a very good
afternoon to you thanks so much for for
joining me in principle do you uh back
the government's plans to tackle
anti-social behavior that we've been
learning about over the last couple of
days
the problem with this plan is that it's
too weak too little and too late we need
strong action to tackle anti-social
Behavior which blights communities but
over the last 13 years the conservatives
have decimated neighborhood policing
undermined Community prevention and
weakened anti-social Behavior Powers so
they're barely ever used and a little
bit of hot spot policing is not we're
nowhere near enough to turn that round
we actually need to get the neighborhood
police teams back and right now there
are still 10 000 fewer neighborhood
police officers and pcsos on our streets
at the moment that is why most people
will say they rarely ever see the police
on the beat labor set out plans for 13
000 more neighborhood police officers
and pcsos that is what we need to
actually take seriously and Tackle
anti-social behavior in our communities
and town centers
and and specifically on on drugs I mean
clearly wanted the headline grabbing
aspects of this that we learned about
yesterday was was Banning nitrous oxide
or laughing gas when you factor in as
well where the UK is at the moment on
cannabis uh which uh still classes as a
Class B drug can can involve five years
in prison for for simply uh possession
relative to a lot of Continental Europe
and the United States are often seen as
comparable Nations to the UK which are
moving in the opposite direction
um are you proud that the UK is is a bit
of an outlier today in terms of of being
fairly tough on drugs like this
well I think what people want to see is
action on prevention action or an
enforcement particularly around the drug
dealing and the criminal gangs and and
where they're operating and also on
treatment as well we support the band
that the government set out but we
actually want to see the the work done
including again I go back to this issue
about the neighborhood police who we
just don't see so I've talked to people
for example who've talked about drug
dealing taking place persistently
outside school Gates they report it to
the police but no one comes and nothing
is done because the police are so
overstretched and they do not have those
neighborhood police and teams so really
it doesn't matter which aspect of
antisocial Behavior or crime that you
look at unless you've got the
neighborhood policing none of it
actually happens none of it is dealt
with in practice
but but the principle of uh Banning
nitrous oxide even though a lot of
Health experts and scientists say say
that's a step too far the principle of
it you do you do agree with yeah but it
needs to be part of a broader strategy
and we're just not seeing that at the
moment you've got to have stronger
prevention so we've talked about work
with young people including labor
sellout plans to have mental health
professionals in all schools to have
youth mentors to work with young people
who are most at risk again we're not
seeing any of those serious plans from
the government and then the neighborhood
police who can work both on prevention
and on tracking down the criminals and
on making sure that there's actually
proper enforcement in place again I go
back to the without the neighborhood
police nothing's going to happen we
couldn't even find a reference to
Neighborhood policing in this entire
anti-social Behavior plan that the prime
minister's set out I just think they're
totally out of touch if they don't get
that you need those police in
communities and on the beat
um I want to touch on immigration as
well clearly the focus is going to be
there this afternoon and uh in the week
ahead if if the government's plans are
too uh too soft uh on anti-social
Behavior are they too tough on on
immigration
I think the problem is that this bill
that they put forward is is a con and
just will make the chaos worse we need
strong action to tackle these dangerous
Boat Crossings that are undermining our
border security and putting lives at
risk that means we need a new Criminal a
new uh cross-border policing unit to go
after the criminal gangs again the
government is still not doing that we
need fast tracking in the Asylum system
to deal with some of the chaos the
backlogs and delays in the Asylum system
and what we need is a new agreement with
France with neighboring countries and
with other European countries to include
both return agreements and also
controlled and manage safe legal routes
and proper security cooperation in place
unless you have that partnership with
France and with other European countries
this issue is simply not going to be
addressed and the real problem is what
they're doing with this bill is they're
going to end up with an even bigger
Asylum backlog even more people stuck in
accommodation and hotel use and just
failing to address the problems with the
criminal gangs
the the Prime Minister said again today
when when asked a question in in Essex
that it's important we abide by our
International obligations obviously it's
a big part of uh of this debate in in
the coming days in principle if that can
be achieved whilst also passing a law
that would allow uh Asylum Seekers to to
be removed to a different safe country
would you agree with that principle if
that difficult uh uh uh needle can be
threaded
the problem is that the government the
government only returns agreements so
they've they've set up a scheme for
Rwanda but the Home Secretary herself
has said that that is failing we know
Rwanda has said they would only take 200
people and in fact 44 000 people arrived
on dangerous small boats last year so
all of the things all of the rhetoric
all of the headline chasing around this
bill simply doesn't stack up it is a con
so actually what they're going to end up
doing well but what they're going to end
up doing is actually ending up with all
of those people ending up indefinitely
in Asylum accommodation and hotels
because they're not going to take Asylum
decisions on those cases if you take
Asylum decisions will those who have
fled persecution and conflict can then
get the support they need and get on
with their lives and those who have not
should be returned and at the moment the
government is not returning people who
have had unsuccessful Asylum
applications that is not happening
either so that's why I think this the
whole thing that the government is
talking about just doesn't work we think
we should be getting agreements with
France and with other European countries
instead
I'm also just wanted to ask about Jeremy
corbyn who obviously won't be a
candidate for labor the next generation
are you pleased about that
well kissed armor has made clear that
all candidates for the labor party have
to abide by the right standards
particularly that means on tackling
anti-Semitism which as you'll recall
there was a very damning report on the
labor party on anti-Semitism by the
equality commission found us in breach
of the law in terms of what happened
before 2019. kirstama has made very
clear that that has to change and
everybody has to abide by the new
standards and it is right that we show
how the party has changed since 2019 and
I think kissed armor has rightly turned
that around thank you so much for
joining us
we're out of time there but much
appreciated